hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his article virtue ethics as a
resource in business robert audi
provides us with some very helpful
analyses of what virtue would actually
entail
that go far beyond the reductive
textbook expositions of virtue ethics
and one of the first things that he's
going to distinguish in
this this article is between what he
calls six dimensions
of virtues and this can apply to
virtue ethics outside of the business
sphere but it's going to be particularly
helpful within the business sphere as
well these all interact with each other
and intersect with each other and he
provides some very useful examples as
well for each of these so we should
remind ourselves first what virtues are
and he tells us this is sort of a common
way of describing it virtues are
praiseworthy traits of character
so you know when we talk about diligence
as something that belongs to a person's
character not just that they displayed
at one point in time and maybe got a
recommendation for but something that we
give them an award for and say they show
diligence day in and day out that would
be a virtue
and
he tells us that it's it's a to have a
virtue is to have a praiseworthy
character trait appropriate to pursuing
the particular kind of good with respect
to which the trait counts as a virtue so
justice the good in question concerns
what's obligatory or permissible in a
moral sense as with a fair distribution
of benefits to a company's worker
generosity
the good is enhancement of well-being
then he tells us that that virtues vary
along many dimensions he's going to talk
about six and here's a really key
important idea
virtues are not on off switches so you
don't suddenly become a just person or a
good leader or anything like that they
they
are along a continuum so like he says
they may be more or less deeply
rooted deeply rooted in a person's
character or personality more or less
dominating in the person's behavior that
is more or less the thing that gets
priority more or less integrated with
other traits of character it's possible
for your virtues to clash with other
virtues or to clash with other parts of
your character as well he says including
non-virtues and conceivably all the
virtues and they're variable in other
potential ways so in giving these six
dimensions of virtue
he is not saying that these are the only
possible dimensions of virtue but he
thinks that these really
help to cover
the domain of what virtue consists in
and these can be incredibly helpful for
you when you're thinking about is my
comportment is the the choices that i'm
making the priorities are they really
virtuous or not
you can sort of go through almost like a
checklist and ask yourself questions
that pertain to these so the first one
that he talks about is field and this
one is absolutely important you don't
have a virtue without some sort of field
that it is acting within how does he
define this the kind of human situation
in which it character characteristically
operates and he gives an example
distributing year-end bonuses to
employees right that's one that could
actually
fall under several different virtues
right it could be
justice
but it could also be as he says right
here beneficence the field of
beneficence is open-ended but
encompasses a wide range of
opportunities for actions affecting
others
particularly as they bear here's what
specifies the field on reducing others
pain enhancing their pleasure providing
them something that is rewarding and he
also points out
that this is a very important
clarification the field is going to be
an area not just of very momentous
decisions but day-to-day activity so
each virtue has a sort of field to it if
we think about
the aristotelian virtues and we talk
about courage that has to do with
feelings right feelings of confidence
and fear it also has to do with choices
and actions
we we have to display courage when we're
dealing with something that is dangerous
or at least perceived as dangerous when
some good is at risk right this might
help us to distinguish courage from
rashness or foolhardiness the person who
acts uh you know in the face of danger
for the purpose of no actual good other
than perhaps you know looking like a
tough guy it's not actually courageous
right so the field is incredibly
important
uh target so the target
is what the virtue is actually aiming at
in that field he says characteristic
targets the virtue leads the agent to
amen for beneficence here's a great
example what is the major target the
well-being of others
for honesty avoidance of deceit for
humility appropriate restraint in
describing one's accomplishments and and
so on and he says that virtues could
have multiple
targets but they're generally going to
have some sort of
thing that they're aiming at some sort
of uh condition some sort of state
closely related to this are the
beneficiaries the people who actually
benefit from realizing that target
within that field you start to see how
these are all connected with each other
so who would be the beneficiaries of
beneficence the people who you're
actually helping out who would be the
beneficiaries of justice people who need
a fair distribution of benefits or harms
or something like that for fidelity he
says that it's very general right
it could be interlocutors
harassing interlocutors in general for
fidelity family friends larger groups
for self-discipline mainly oneself but
perhaps other people as well if they're
dependent on you so beneficiaries is is
quite important and aristotle expressed
this and saying it's not enough to do
the right thing you have to do it in
relation to the right people right so
exercising beneficence by walking around
and just throwing dollar bills around
probably not actually beneficence there
it's probably spendthriftness or
showoffiness or something like that
agency agential understanding the
understanding on the part of the agent
of the field in question this is more
cognitive and this requires that the
person actually understand what they're
doing so again if we take beneficence if
you don't actually understand how money
works and for example that credit cards
need to be paid back taking out money on
credit cards in order to walk around the
street uh handing out dollar bills
probably not exercising that virtue you
have to have some understanding of what
you're doing for example he says
criteria for benefiting others
he also specifies this doesn't have to
be perfect but you can't hit a target
without a good sense of where it is or
what means will hit it
another incredibly important one
motivation the agent's motivation to act
appropriately in that field in a certain
way the way fitting to that virtue so
he's got a great example here
take a desire to contribute to the
well-being of customers as opposed to
just wanting just profits
the former that is contributing to the
well-being of customers
but not the latter desire befits
beneficence you're not really being
beneficent if the only reason why you're
being beneficent is to improve the
bottom line so what's often called the
business case for ethics meaning you
should act ethically because it's going
to help your bottom line
not really virtuous it's not the right
motivation uh the right motivation is to
do the right thing because it's it's the
the right or the good thing
in that field uh with all of these other
things in mind
so he says that we have to do not just
good deeds but have good motives
particularly intentions and here he
talks about one that plays a major role
in business good will
as a matter of fact when you sell a
business
you
are actually
tar you're factoring in what we call the
good will of the customers it's not
exactly the same thing as this but it is
a kind of motivation good will can
actually overcome a lot of problems so
motivation is really central finally we
have grounding and this refers to
the development of the disposition right
how rooted
is it in the person's character the
grounding he says is a psychological
grounding of the relevant action
tendencies the right dispositions to do
the these things and to think through
things the right way he also calls it
the attach the attachment of the action
to the virtue that it should reflect
which is a very nice way to talk about
it so we want it to be as he says
sufficiently a sufficiently strong
disposition to act on the understanding
and motivation that are the basis
appropriate appropriate to manifesting
that virtue so for example a just person
is going to want to do the right thing
in distributing
benefits to different people or you know
distributing uh things that that might
be harms in some respect we all have to
take a cut
you know should leadership take a bigger
cut to their paycheck and benefits than
the employees that's a great question
for the domain of justice right you
might say well
we'll all take a five percent cut but
maybe you actually get better results if
leadership takes a ten percent cut
because they can afford it more unless
they're like mortgage to the hilt which
would be a imprudence on their part
right then the employees who are kind of
close to
you know
close to
insolvency right so
all of these play a major role in
whether or not you have a virtue and
whether you're going to be exercising a
virtue each of these can be
distinguished apart from the others but
you notice that they all connect up with
each other so they form a kind of
integrated whole that then we call a
virtue like generosity or
good leadership or prudence or justice
so this can be a very helpful way of
breaking down
what a virtue actually involves
you